Very excited to have a distinguished professor
and Presidential Chair in Information Studies
at UCLA, Christine Borgman.
She is highly accomplished and she's the author
of more than 250 publications in information
studies, computer science, and communication.
And at UCLA she directs the Center for Knowledge
Infrastructures with research grants from
the Alfred P Sloan Foundation, the National
Science Foundation, and many other sources.
She is a world authority on data science,
data sharing, information sciences and how
that can be communicated effectively.
She is the author of several books, including
one I'm sure she's going to mention in her
presentation.
We're absolutely delighted to have her.
As well as her colleague Irene Pasquetto,
who's a research assistant also at the Center
for Knowledge Infrastructures.
She's also a PhD candidate in the Department
of Information Studies at UCLA.
And she's working on her dissertation on data
sharing, reuse practices in molecular biology
and genomics.
And she has research interests in open science
frameworks, science governance models, and
in more general, the ethics and policies behind
data sharing, code sharing, and other practices
for open science.
We're absolutely delighted to have the both
of you.
We look forward to your presentation I'd like
to take this opportunity to remind our listeners
that you have an opportunity to send in your
questions via the little GoToWebinar question
submission system during the talk.
In the last few minutes of the hour, we'll
take some time to read off some of those questions
for our speakers and get some answers to them.
So without further delay, Dr. Borgman thank
you so much for taking the time to speak with
us today.
And Dr. Pasquetto as well.
Thank you, Jack and [? Crystal ?] and to the
whole group.
And it's an honor to be part of this.
As you said in the introductions, we've been
working with the National Science Foundation
and the Sloan Foundation.
And a little bit more indirectly with the
National Institutes of Health.
Because one of the projects that we're studying
that Irene will talk about, as the case study
here that is her dissertation, is funded by
NIH.
And then I'm of course, a number of coordinating
bodies, including a strategic planning panel
for data for the NIH and National Library
of Medicine.
Why data sharing and reuse are hard to do
is a huge and book-length topic.
Certainly more than we can do in 45 minutes
or so today.
So what we hope to do is give you a larger
frame, and point you to some other sources
to think about it.
I'll spend the first 15 or 20 minutes giving
a big picture, and then Irene will do her
case study.
And I'll come back and do the wrap-up.
For starters I want to give you this larger
framing around data sharing policies.
We've been thinking about open access to publications
and open data in various ways for several
decades.
And we've had open data repositories
for 50 years or more in areas such as genomics,
social sciences, surveys, and so on.
But it's really been ramping up in the last
5-10 years.
The [? Holdren ?] memo from the White House
and the Obama Administration was the one that
required open access to publications and to
data for all US large funding agencies.
The European Commission has been even more
aggressive in declaring that open science--
open-access publications-- and open data are
official policy of the European Union.
And so all new grants going forward are required
to have open data.
They are making very specific plans, not only
through the rest of the [? horizon ?] [? 2020,
?] but into the 9th framework program, which
will run from 2021 to 2028.
And really thinking about this as the future
approach.
So the challenge then is to think about how
you actually accomplish open data and reuse
on the ground.
Now the book of mine that Dr. Van Horn mentioned,
that came out about two years ago from MIT
Press, I surveyed a wide range of policies
up to that point.
And I was able to categorize the various motivations
and arguments in these public policy documents
into four general categories.
The one that you hear most often is that research
data should be shared, so that we can reproduce
research.
And in some cases that's feasible and possible.
But it's actually extremely difficult and
extremely contentious in most fields, as to
what reproducibility actually means.
It tends to be in more computational areas
that reproducibility is actually feasible
or accomplishable.
We can do things.
We can verify, we can validate, we can replicate,
but true reproducibility is probably the biggest
challenge of all.
The second category is making public assets
available to the public.
On the grounds that most big science, including
most public health and medicine research,
is accomplished with public funding-- with
taxpayer dollars, euros, yen and so on-- is
that the public should have access to the
publications and to the data.
They should be useful for research purposes.
Thirdly to leverage the investments.
It costs a great deal of money, no matter
what the currency [? is, ?] to accomplish
the research and to produce the data.
So in what ways can we leverage those data
and make them useful for other purposes across
time?
Again, not easy to do.
But these are large goals.
The last one, which in many respects is cumulative,
is to advance research and innovation.
On the-- at least theoretical-- grounds that
if you make data more widely available, other
people can use it for [? unseen ?] purposes.
Ask new questions, build new programs, even
build new companies.
So all of those reasons are why public policy
around the world, especially in the western
world, are moving very quickly in the direction
of open science and open data.
However we also know from a decade or two
of social science research that it's hard
to do for many reasons, not
the least of which is the lack of incentives.
Scholars collaborate with each other but they
also compete.
The first one to a finding gets priority,
no matter what the prize is, whatever the
journal article is, whatever the best job
is.
Scholars in all fields, including biomedicine,
are rewarded much more for publications than
for releasing data.
One of the aspects of these problems that
our group is looking at in most depth is around
the practices associated with documenting
data, and making them available in a form
that other people can use.
And we'll talk about that today.
The skills to document metadata [? provenance
?] version control, connecting data to the
software, the tools, the calibration, the
instruments, is often a set of skills that's
different from the set of skills that's required
to accomplish the research.
The information studies field is a part of
the data sciences where we're trying to educate
a new generation of professionals to facilitate
those aspects.
Lastly but by no means least are questions
of control and of ownership.
It's contentious as to who actually owns data.
You often have many hands many, many universities
in the pot.
You've got different kinds of funding models.
This is a wide open area, and questions of
legal interoperability are among those on
the table in larger discussions of open access
to data.
Where our group is spending its time is, right
now I'm really looking at questions of reuse.
In our opinion data sharing should not be
viewed as an end in itself.
Releasing the data doesn't get you very far
if you don't release them in such a way that
other people actually can reuse them.
And these are some of the reasons that you
might want to reuse them to reproduce-- as
we talked about-- to replicate, to do it again--
not necessarily by the same methods and means--
to verify, to validate.
We have found in our other research in other
fields over the years that sometimes people
are seeking data to reuse to ask new questions.
But other times they're using them for validation
or comparison.
Almost background purposes.
Getting them from, say, government sources
of field ground-- ground truthing, it's called
in the environmental sciences.
And lastly to integrate with other data, and
you'll be hearing more about that in the case
study.
Integrating requires cleaning, reconciling,
standardizing in ways that also can be a major
undertaking in and of themselves.
So now to think about what are data in the
first place.
We've also found that one person's signal
is someone else's noise.
Just deciding what are the data out of a research
project in the first place can be one of the
most daunting challenges to get to the place
where you could actually make data usable
by some other parties.
Here's an example that is on the one hand,
a bit far afield from biomedicine.
But one that's straight forward to explain
the signal-to-noise issues.
We were part of the Center for Embedded Network
Sensing for the 10 years of its existence
as a National Science Foundation science and
technology center.
This image is one from networked infomechanical
systems, built by
some electrical engineering teams and many
partners.
And it was a huge advance forward in environmental
sciences, because you could get data at far
more granularity and more speed from the air,
the water, the ground and look for things
like different kinds of harmful algal blooms,
looking at things like methylmercury contamination
in rice fields.
Some very important environmental problems
being studied this way.
As we would interview people, we would find
things like an engineering researcher would
say, temperature's temperature.
If he's getting the same signal from one day
to the next on his temperature sensor, he's
happy, he thinks it's working.
And for his standards, for his kinds of science,
it's adequate.
We asked a biologist on the same team the
same question.
And this long narrative here on the right
is just a sample from what we got.
He has to deal with international standards
set by his field about the way in which you
trust temperature.
And the measurements that the engineer would
get was not adequate.
He could not publish in a biological journal
with those measurements, because they view
them very, very differently.
Now neither of these people is right or wrong.
They're both correct with respect to their
field.
And that, I think, again is one of the fundamental
challenges with data sharing.
This image here and the quote from my book,
the Big Data, Little Data, No Data, is where
I ended up with a somewhat phenomenological
definition of data.
To say that they are representations that
become data at the point that you use them
as evidence of phenomena.
So almost anything in our world could be data,
but it's not data and you declare it to be
data and declare it to be some kind of evidence.
Again, much of what we do is look at those
processes by which someone's signals become
evidence or some kind of phenomena.
This next slide gives you the title of our
current large three-year grant from the Sloan
Foundation, which is if data sharing is the
answer, what is the question?
So we're looking broadly at why people are
trying to share data, and what it is they're
trying to accomplish.
So we're trying to explicate these concepts
such as data sharing, reuse, openness, and
infrastructure across different kinds of domains,
look at how practice is changing.
And we've called out these three factors,
which again I'll discuss briefly.
Those mixtures or combinations or configurations
of expertise from different disciplines, scale
factors.
Is it a matter of the volume of data, the
time period, or what other factors?
Then thirdly-- and this is the centralization
one-- really comes to bear in questions of
biomedical research.
So again I'll go through very briefly, and
note that we have publications on all of these
topics already that you'll find linked from
the Center for Knowledge Infrastructures website.
We use qualitative methods.
We do a lot of digging of publications and
web sites.
We try to get the official story and the unofficial
story about what people are trying to accomplish.
Our grad students and researchers spend
long periods of time on-site.
Irene has been working with this particular
biomedical group for about 2 and 1/2 years
already, really working with them, visiting
their sites around other parts of the US.
And only when we understand a site well enough
to be able to ask really specific questions
do we come in and start doing interviews.
And she'll talk a bit more about how many
interviews and where she is in the process
for this particular study.
Here's a sampling of the sites that we're
in right now.
We're not that big a team as it looks like
this, but we have been in some of these for
nearly 10 years, and some of them for only
a year or so.
And I won't talk about them in any depth.
The order in here is more about how long we've
been looking at them.
What's useful it is that we have enough breadth
to get some strong comparisons.
Looking at astronomy that's focused on a place,
the sky and the universe.
The earth sciences, where they're drilling
under the sea floor.
The biomedical and the computational science
are both looking at particular kinds of problems.
And the biomedical one is around data sharing
and reuse in what is remarkably interdisciplinary
context compared to the kinds of research
usually done in these fields.
The first question, then, is that one of mixtures.
No matter how narrow a field looks, when you
start digging deeper you find that people
have graduate degrees from different disciplines,
different departments, different theoretical
orientations.
They use different software, different instrumentation/
all of these things come together to influence
the collection, the use, and the reuse of
data.
The Sloan Digital Sky Survey which has been
running-- actually the main parts of it, the
first two parts ran from 2000 to 2008.
But it was a decade or two before that for
the design.
The 160 or more terabytes of data looked like
a vast amount at the time they were building
it.
It's not so big by today's standards.
Again, the tens of millions of dollars that
they spent, the new projects are much bigger
than that.
The Sloan Digital Sky Survey is notable because
it was built to be open data to the world
for education and research from the first
day.
But it was built on proprietary software in
collaboration with Jim Gray of the Microsoft
Corporation, who's also a Turing Award winner
in computer science.
The Large Synoptic Survey Telescope, that
is going to get 15 terabytes per night.
And they're spending more than a billion dollars
on it.
It's well over a decade along already.
And we're about five years out.
The target of course keeps moving forward.
Then they plan to get data for about 10 years.
There, they've got the problem of how you
actually build a data commons, how you deal
with free rider problems, and they're still
brokering what partners are going to have
access to it.
But they're investing in open source software.
So they're taking a different route even than
Sloan did in how they're approaching open
data.
What are the mixtures?
Many of these astronomers have all of their
degrees in physics.
Others come up through much more observational
astronomy, a great deal of computer sciences
mixed in.
One of the people we're working with takes
PhD students in astronomy, in physics, and
in computer science.
This project is a mature discipline.
They have vast amounts of data, abundant data.
They have a long history of the infrastructure,
trusted archives.
And they've been doing these methods for a
long time.
And that's true across all of these.
By comparison, in the sciences, we've been
looking at the C-DEBI the Center for Dark
Energy Biosphere Investigations, that gets
most of its data by drilling under the sea
floor.
This also is a National Science Foundation
science and technology center that collaborates
at about 35 institutions across the US, and
then it made grants to those even more.
This photo on the right is what we might call
a library.
It's a repository.
It's an open data repository.
But those are frozen ice cores from under
the sea floor and those specimens are their
primary data source.
This drawing that our collaborator, Peter
Darch, has driven shows you how all those
cores come off one set of cruises.
But the physical science people take them
down one path, and the microbiological-- the
ones we're studying-- take them down another
path.
I think what was most striking to us here
is that decisions that are made on-board the
ship are absolutely critical to who can make
data out of these.
For the physical sciences, the line down the
left, you can store those cores at minus 4
centigrade.
For the microbiological down the right, you
have to be able to store them at minus 80
centigrade.
So unless those are frozen cold enough on
the ship, they can never again be used for
biological research.
So those early decisions are critical long-term
in use and in reuse of data.
So here the mixtures are on the domains.
Many different specialties, and again we have
papers on this about the mix of them working
together.
This is a much more emergent problem.
The data are scarce.
They are not able to set standards yet because
you get one core here, you get one core there.
Many different questions and very exploratory
kinds of methods.
So they're trying to build capacity as opposed
to the huge capacity that exists in astronomy.
I'm going to go brief on these other couple
of questions so that we have time for the
case study.
The scale factors.
Big data is usually what people think is the
problem.
But rather, we're seeing many other kinds
of scale are critical.
This notion of the three V's goes back a decade
or so.
Goes from the business world to say that the
complexity of data is a function not only
in volume, but of the variety, the heterogeneity,
and the velocity, the speed at which it's
coming at you.
We see the temporal characteristics are important.
The spatial characteristics and the variety
of personnel and the number of personnel also
to be key.
Here's just one example of that, is to look
at the two astronomy projects.
Look at this range of time.
45 years from the time of inception of the
first one of these, until the end of the data
collection and beyond.
The kinds of uncertainty these people have
to deal with is also how they're thinking
about how you build an open source, how you
think about data, how you think about sharing.
So again briefly on the scale factors, and
we've published some of these elsewhere for
you to think about.
But there's the uncertainty in the long temporal.
There's the scarce data that are sparse.
There's the variety of genomes studied.
And then, again, big differences in some of
these computational areas we're looking at.
Thirdly-- and I do want to use this as a setup
for a [? remnants ?] case study around how
the degree of centralization matters.
We tried to compare what happens in areas
like astronomy, where you spent a decade building
the instruments, building the data management
functions, so that you can pull a large archive
together that everybody can use.
As opposed to working independently, which
is much more common in biomedical.
And trying to integrate them later.
That, in many respects, is a much harder problem
than the kind of problem that astronomy is
dealing with.
So with that, let me turn it over to Irene
who's sitting here next to me.
And she will give you the example.
And again she's been in here for almost 2
and 1/2 years now.
The dissertation will come out about a year
from now in spring of 2018.
And I think that it's going to be a very important
contribution, not only to information studies,
but to the biomedical areas in thinking about
reuse.
So, Irene.
Good morning, this is Irene.
Thank you Chris for the great overview on
this important topic.
In my dissertation work I really look at the
practices of better use and integration in
the scientific collaboration.
I'm very interested in looking at what happens
to research data once they are made available,
once they are shared.
So I'm asking questions such as, who is reusing
the data once they're available in open repositories.
Why and how?
My main case study is consortium for data
sharing biomedicine.
Over the last 2 years and 1/2, I conducted
over 100 hours of interviews and observations.
And over 30 interviews with the participants
of this consortium.
We have 10 labs involved in this collaboration.
And they are geographically distributed all
over the United States, plus a team of engineers.
The scientists investigated the [? body.
?] In this collaboration, they investigated
the developmental and genetic factors involved
in a set of rare syndromes.
It is, as you can understand, a highly interdisciplinary
effort.
Indeed, the investigators span the molecular
and developmental biology.
Computational biology, [? Maggie's ?] [? team,
?]
computer engineers but also computer modeling.
The goal behind this collaboration is really
to fund a collection of these new and advanced
genomic and imaging data that is related to
these rare syndromes.
And by making all the data openly available
for use, the goal is to encourage collaborative
efforts and systemic approaches to [? knowledge
?] [? and ?] discovery.
Also to make the data sharing process and
reuse [? fostering ?] also collaboration happening
faster.
Scientists who are collaborating in this consortium,
they are expected to make all their research
data available prior to publication.
Which means that as soon as the data are collected,
cleaned, curated, they are ready to be shipped.
Just a little bit more about this consortium
and their work.
The data collected this this community includes
patients images, the metric [? score ?] anatomy
norms.
Phenotypic images and sequences from [? genomic-wide
?] association studies.
But there's the results from gene proteins
functional validation studies.
This is one of the challenges of these consortiums,
that data are collected from four different
model organisms.
So we have humans, mice, zebra fish, and chimpanzee.
So as you understand, it's a really heterogeneous
set of actors.
So I want to present now my findings so far.
As Chris was saying I will graduate in a year
or so.
So I'm still in the process of finishing my
data collection.
But I have quote some data.
So in terms of data sharing practices, what
we are finding is that most of the labs involve
them.
They really didn't have any particular problems
with making their data openly available on
the shared repository.
We were partially surprised.
Because initially we expected a scientist
to be kind of reluctant to share their data
prior to publication.
But this really didn't happen.
Almost all the data sets are indeed collected
by the community and are available on the
centralized database created by the consortium.
However, when we look at we should be using
the data and how, a set of concerns and challenges
emerged.
So basically what we are finding is that reusing
this unpublished data is much more difficult
than sharing the data sets.
We found that data use practices are not homogeneous.
But they really vary by skills, expertise,
disciplinary focus, and types of data.
So on one hand, we found some shared concerns
across most of the scientists about data use.
On the other hand, we found that some disciplinary-specific
challenges.
So now I'm going to go through my findings.
OK.
So let's start with the common issues with
data reuse.
First, we found that almost all the scientists
involved in this collaboration, they expressed
concerns over using unpublished data.
So from the [? funder's ?] point of view,
sharing data prior to publication is of course
presented as a strategy to increase efficiency
and making collaboration across labs faster.
However, from a scientist's point of view,
reusing data prior to publication represented
a breach in the ways of establishing trust
in others' data.
So most of the scientists reported that when
they have to decide if they want to trust
or not specifically a given data set, the
fact that that data set is associated to a
specific study that's being published in academic
journal, plays a really important role for
them to decide whether or not to trust this
data set.
Second point.
We also found that most study participants
expressed concerns over the quality of others'
data.
So scientists reported that about multiple
occasions, in which they invested a lot of
time and effort and resources trying to validate
others' data sets in order to use them.
However, on multiple occasions they found
these data sets not to be acute, accurate
or not working.
For this reason, the scientists-- they tend
to reuse published data mostly in the context
of a research collaboration where they have
personal knowledge of those who collected
the data.
Mainly because they know it is difficult to
go through this process of violating others'
data for use because it takes a lot of time.
So they want to avoid that.
If they already know the scientist who collected
the data, they can skip this process.
OK.
My last point here is that, probably because
of this lack of trust in unpublished data
and concerns about data quality, some participants
are accessing and downloading the data from
the consortium database to the goal of comparing
these data to the ones they collected themselves.
So the scientists are still collecting data
sets.
And then they are downloading also, kind of
the same type of data set from the consortium
database in order to make comparisons and
do some sort of quality control.
But they're not really reusing others' data
for knowledge production.
So we can see that in this case, the application
of that for it is not avoided.
It's a little bit twisted, so if you have
questions about this, in the Q&A I can explain
better.
I don't want to give too many details right
now.
But this is that idea.
OK.
So I just went out.
I selected two disciplinary-specific concerns
about data reuse and I think they're interesting.
So first of all, belonging to a specific domain
or having a particular set of skills really
influenced the way in which the data were
accessed and reused by the community.
And this seems obvious.
However, whenever you make available data,
you really have to keep in mind that you have
different types of users out there.
And this means that you have to share data
in different formats, a different level of
processing, provide different type of data
analysis tools and so on.
And my last point is related to some concerns
about reusing data and the [? presumation
?] of results.
So let me explain you this.
Some of the scientists-- and not all of them,
but some of the scientists-- involved in this
collaboration, they work on particularly rare
syndromes that are characterized by scarcity
of data.
So in other
words, there is really no data or very few
specialized data available for these syndromes.
So what some scientists are doing, they are
reusing data collected by colleagues and available
on the consortium database for their experiments.
However, this data is close enough to what
they're looking for, but it's not exactly
what they're looking for.
Some other scientists are really concerned
about this practice.
Because they are worried that by reusing the
that it is close enough, but is not exactly
what they need, this could lead to misleading
results.
So again I can give more specific examples
about these in the Q&A.
So in general, what I think we should-- especially
when we design policies for data sharing,
reuse, or infrastructures for data sharing
and reuse, I think we should keep in mind
that data reuse is not a homogeneous practice
but a set of practices.
We should think about data reuse really as
a process, rather than as a one-time action.
And then also we should keep in mind that
data are validated at multiple times during
the research process, and validating others'
data for reuse takes a lot of time and effort.
Thank you, Irene.
As you can see, this is going to be a very
important contribution to the literature of
biomedicine as well as the literature of information
studies.
So I thought this was a good preview of it
for this audience.
And we also have several publications already
covering some of these topics that you can
find and are linked.
So let me give you just a few wrap-up slides.
First, to summarize our research themes.
The domains consist of multiple [? subdomains.
?] And as you can see, again in this case
study, we've got many different areas within
this biomedicine.
And the fact that you've got four different
model organisms, which is a far more complex
set of comparisons than is usually done in
biomedicine.
It's a good comparison to areas like the earth
sciences, where people self-identify with
50 or 60 different sub-domains.
And still they're trying to share data, bring
them together, and use them.
So big data is a problem.
We all know that.
But it's not the only part of the problem
is the bigness.
It may be how long it is, how diverse it is,
what kind of distribution of geography, of
language, of laboratories, of specimens are
involved as far as scale factors.
The centralized collections-- things like
the astronomy ones, become decentralized in
analysis.
You might look at something as big and relatively
homogeneous as the Sloan Digital Sky Survey.
But you may take pieces of that, and then
combine them with pieces from the Hubble Space
Telescope, from Chandra, from Keck and others.
So they become de-centralized when you start
to analyze them.
The de-centralized data collections processes,
like this biomedical sharing, when you're
trying to bring them back together and again
later, those are often the most difficult
to integrate.
And in that sense, some of the data reuse
problems in biomedicine are probably as difficult
as almost any other science.
And certainly of the ones that we've
looked at in the last decade or two.
Some of the conclusions that we find.
Data can be shared in many ways.
Sharing point-to-point, sharing with your
colleagues, you have the best chance of transferring
the knowledge-- particularly the tacit knowledge--
that goes with it.
But that doesn't scale well.
Something like this biomedical sharing hub,
where you're trying to scale by getting different
groups around the country to put things into
[? commonhood, ?] scales better but you can
see the kinds of trust issues that arise.
We feel strongly that data sharing should
not be viewed as an end in itself, but rather
a means to reuse.
And much more research and public policy should
look at these questions around reuse.
We know that reuse requires considerable knowledge
about the data.
Not just what was collected, but why it was
collected.
What the research questions were will tell
you quite a bit about what kinds of decisions
that were made.
The validation, the trust in the data, occurs
at multiple stages.
Questions such as data quality, again, are
rising to the top.
That data quality is at least as much a matter
of social trust and social relationships as
it is anything that is inherent in the data,
per se.
Stewardship and sustainability is something
we have not talked very much about today.
And there is experimentation going on by NIH,
by NSF, by the European Commission, and others
funding in this area about, should the responsibility
for stewardship live with the investigator?
With the institution?
With the collaborator?
With the individually universities?
With the funding agencies?
And all of these different models are being
tried.
The trust is definitely the overarching concern
when you think about data reuse.
What does this mean for practice?
Many if not most of you are trying to share
and reuse data.
You may be running data repositories.
You may be data scientists, data librarians,
archivists, research facilitators.
Some suggestions here are to think not about
how is it done in astronomy, but how is it
done in this particular kind of sub-domain,
and how does this sub-domain interact with
others?
We need to think about what the level of abstraction
is for data sharing and integration before
we can think much about curation and reuse.
Should we be thinking about point-to-point?
Should we be thinking about contributing to
some large curated long-term memory model
where you've really got a long-term commitment,
like libraries and archives?
The sooner in a project that a group invests
in data curation, the more likely you are
to create data that are going to be useful
indefinitely.
Decisions made in the earliest stages around
what kind of documentation, what kind of data
reduction you're going to do, will carry forward.
If it's collapsed too soon, you will never
be able to separate those variables again,
later for example.
We encourage infrastructure solutions to think
about shared tools and services, and different
kinds of discovery
mechanisms, recognizing that stewardship is
going to have to be iterative.
The way that you keep and manage data during
the course of a one-, two-, or five-year grant
is going to be different than the way a lab
manages over the course of investigator's
career, or how a university or a funding agency
manages long-term.
Back to the kinds of questions being asked
internationally, the European Commission,
through pretty much through a gauntlet at
the Research Data Alliance meeting in Barcelona
two weeks ago, saying that the Ninth Framework
Project will invest somewhere on the order
of 80 billion to 100 billion euros of public
money in research funding between 2021 and
2028.
All of that will be going into research that
is necessarily data-intensive and compute-intensive.
They don't want to see every single group
trying to solve their data problems individually.
They want to see much more in the way of community
efforts, of infrastructural solutions and
approaches.
And so the Research Data Alliance is but one
place where people are trying to come together
to think about broader kinds of solutions,
rather than each lab, each group, each university
trying to do these individually.
Because these are very big and very large
problems.
Let's end with just a slight of acknowledgements.
Again, this is a team project.
The six of us are the ones currently involved.
Peter Darch, who is now an assistant professor
at the University of Illinois, Information
School is leading the astronomy work and the
undersea biosphere work.
Ashley Sands, who's now at the Institute for
Museum and Library Services as a program officer,
has been working in the astronomy areas.
Irene you've just heard from the biomedical.
Bernadette, known as Bernie Randles, is working
in astronomy and computational sciences.
And Milena Golshan, here in Los Angeles is
our data scientist and project manager who
keeps all these pieces together.
So, very much a collaborative effort.
And we have had a number of other people graduate
from this group that we continue to collaborate
with.
So it's been a team effort.
And I hope you will explore some of our publications
and other work that we have done that explores
these questions across a number of different
disciplines.
Let me stop there and leave 15 minutes for
questions.
Because surely we have provoked a number of
You have indeed, Christine.
Thank you so much to Christine and Irene for
a really great survey of a lot of the data
sharing activities which are going on, not
only in biomedicine but also in many other
domains, too, struggle with the same problem
of this as you pointed out.
This very rapid fire hose of data which is
coming at us and how we deal with that.
How we share it, turn it outwards so that
it can be maximally used by people.
A couple of questions have come in.
And they are asking about the role of various
organizations and institutions on how to promote
and encourage this.
One particular-- I want to just extend that
a little bit.
Because I don't
remember if you touched on this or not, but
what's the role of journals in promoting data
sharing, encouraging it, and using shared
data to support the content of the peer-reviewed
literature?
Do you have any comments on that?
Yes I do, and again we covered a lot of territory
here in a short time.
Journals are certainly a very important part
of the infrastructure.
And many journals, I think, pioneering in
biomedicine have required people to deposit
data sets in public repositories as a condition
of funding the work.
And that certainly promotes open science.
The trade-off there is that we would like
to see those data be deposited in repositories
that are open.
So that you can get them and compare them
and look at them over time.
If you publish things with a journal and the
data set only exists in, say, supplemental
materials and it's behind a pay wall, it may
be useful for validating or verifying that
journal article.
But it may not be in some common standard
data structure where it can be reused by the
community.
So in our research, we would say that the
optimal model would be for the journal to
require the data deposit, but to deposit in
a public repository, such as those run by
the National Institutes of Health, and then
provide a link and relationship.
Phil Bourne-- I think about 2005-- as the
editor of the PLOS Computational Biology journal,
wrote a very nice little editorial talking
about how we should think about the database
of journal literature and the database of
observational data as almost interchangeable.
And the richer you could have those links
and relationships, the better you could [? mine.
?] Start with the data, go to the journal.
Start the journal, go to the data, and so
on.
So let's think in terms of as synergistic
a relationship as possible.
Great.
One other question is-- some people are asking,
what sort of analyses are you seeing come
out of the use of shared data?
Then, how do you measure the impactfulness
of that reuse?
Does that make sense?
The impactfulness of re-uses.
Yeah.
So for example, can one measure the impactfulness
of, say, somebody taking data from a shared
repository and, through their analysis they're
seeing a new publication coming out in, maybe
Science or Nature-- a high-impact factor journal.
And perhaps that's a measure of its potential
impactfulness.
Or perhaps its being cited a lot so its citation
index is really big.
I don't know, are you able to track that sort
of thing?
Because it always seems that people are a
little bit wary about sharing data because
they're not really sure it adds any value.
Because once people have done their initial
analysis, that they've wrung all the useful
stuff out of it.
Are you getting a sense that there's value
beyond that initial publication done by the
original authors that has some impact on the
field?
Yes, so this is Irena.
So the situation that you described is definitely
the ideal situation, where you have a scientist
who is downloading a data set and running
a new analysis, finding new things, and publishing
new articles with these new analyses.
However-- so I've been observing and conducting
interviews with this community for almost
three years now.
The fact is that even data use takes a lot
of time.
So at least in my case study, they just started
to reuse each other data, the scientists.
But-- so first of all, it doesn't really happen--
or at least I haven't seen this so far-- that
you have a scientist who goes on this repository
and downloads a data set and run a new analysis.
It's always in the context of a collaboration.
So first, what I'm really finding is that
scientists, they establish a collaboration.
And then together, they work out the order
[? shape, ?] and who is taking care of which
part of the new analysis.
So even when you have a reanalysis, I think
it's always in the context of a collaboration.
It takes a lot of time and effort.
Yes, I think Chris wants to add something
here.
I'm going to take that up to a higher level
and think about the different kinds of uses
and re-uses.
Looking at the impact or the contribution
of an individual reuse is no easier than looking
at the contribution of any other kind of paper.
So I think the measurement is always going
to be a challenge.
We can look for those.
One of the larger questions is the difficulty
of distinguishing between a use and a reuse.
And we have a paper that just came out in
The Data Science Journal on exactly that problem.
So if you think about people [? doing-- ?] building
data sets, some groups, their primary work,
even in biomedicine, is to produce data that
other people can use.
And so if those people weren't just plain
data producers, those data would not be there
in the first place.
Similarly, if some astronomers were not willing
to dedicate their careers to astronomy sky
surveys, those data would not be there for
anyone else to use.
So is the first use of evidence from a sky
survey or evidence from a genome survey, is
that a use or is that a reuse?
That is an unanswered question.
So there is a lot of definitional issues here
before we start to try to put numbers on things.
The other piece is on citation indicators.
And data citation is something, again, we
put a lot of time into.
I encourage you to look at Chapter 9 of my
book, which is on credit and attribution of
data, which are really very different kinds
of things.
People use data from other sources that they
do not cite.
So for example, Irene's comparison between
pulling data to validate your own versus pulling
data for a new research question.
We found the same thing in [? SENS ?] 10 years
ago.
Where, if they were using it for background
calibration, they were using it but they didn't
cite it.
It was part of a new research question, then
they would cite it.
So whatever indicators you're seeing are a
floor.
By no means are they a ceiling.
And we're only at the beginning of people
actually putting things like digital object
identifiers onto their data sets.
Look at DataSite and look at the work the
California Digital Library and others are
doing on indicators.
So until people start being more consistent
about citing their own data and telling people
where they are, and citing data they use from
other people, it's going to be difficult to
get those kinds of indicators.
That's great, we've had a couple of questions
with regard to data provenance as well as
common data standards for storage and for
describing how data have been treated.
This also links into the software tools and
other processing methods that people have
used as part of their processing workflows.
How important is it to link not only the data,
but to the tools and the software, utilities
that people have performed on the data as
pertaining to tracking where that data came
from and what's happened to it?
Did Phillip Boren feed you
that question?
No.
That's an absolutely essential question, and
again, something we could easily have delved
into here and something that's of great concern
to us.
And it's one Bernie Randles of our group,
her dissertation's going to look more at that.
In many cases, if you don't have the software,
you don't have the data.
I mean let's face it.
It would be hard to find a research project
these days that doesn't have some kind of
software associated with generating those
data.
So you need to tie those together and you
need to link them.
So things like the workflow models, Taverna
and others, the computational models, Carole
Goble's work in Britain in biomedicine are
ones to look at there.
We've particularly good looking at Jupyter
Notebooks and GitHub on some of the tools
that people use to tie together their publications,
their data, and their software.
And we have a piece that's in interview right
now on the Jupyter Notebooks in astronomy,
and we'll certainly be looking at those in
biomedicine and others.
Do you want to add that, Irene?
Yeah, no I agree with everything you said,
Chris.
We did these analyses of how people are using
the Jupyter Notebooks again, to cite their
data and then to link the data with software.
And again, what we are finding in this other
research is that even the ways in which you
can use the Jupyter Notebooks and you can
store your data in different places and link
it to the publication, [? through ?] the software,
it's not really standardized yet.
There are many different ways in which you
can actually do that, provide both the data
and the software as a package.
And we are definitely looking into new tools
that can, and how efficient these tools are
in enabling this process.
Right.
Certainly.
That needs to be done.
But let me put one note of caution there,
is the rush to standards can be
risky.
There's always going to be a trade-off in
the point at which you want to standardize
so that you can really get that integration
and that interoperability in areas where you
really still need to be pretty exploratory
and maybe not let 1,000 flowers bloom but
let 500 bloom, where you're still working
it out.
And if you standardize too quickly you're
going to lose certain lines of investigation.
So this is one of the things we're seeing
in the undersea biosphere.
It's pretty scarce data, emergent kinds of
standards and practices.
It's a little too soon and they're wrestling
with getting standards there.
Where astronomy is working from standards
called FITS files that were established in
the late 1970s.
And they're stretching those to the breaking
point and trying to decide what's the next
step for them.
I think those are very interesting points
about standards.
And it always seems to me that-- I've been
involved with several standards groups that
I've been participating with over the years.
And just when you think you've got the standard,
you finally fleshed it out and whatnot, you
say, OK ta-dah, here's the standard, there's
some other group that pops up like a mushroom
after a rainstorm with, oh no we're going
to define the standard!
And you end up getting a little bit of this
not-invented-here syndrome.
Do you have any thoughts on how to socially
engineer that out or is it just to be expected?
Well the good thing about standards is there's
so many to choose from.
That's right Maybe that's just the way it
is.
I don't know.
But it would be nice be a little more uniformity
of it.
I think what we need to do is bring the communities
together.
And that's what's been so good about the Research
Data Alliance which has grown.
This was established four years ago, but the
first meeting got about 300 people.
This meeting in Barcelona two weeks ago, had
620 people from 45 countries.
And the membership is up to 5,400 people from
almost 125 countries in four years.
That's amazing.
It is amazing.
And it's the first place where people from
biomedicine and archeology and astronomy and
agriculture and the United Nations could all
be in one room talking about questions like
provenance and versioning and integration
and data citation and software side citation.
And software sustainability and data sustainability.
So I would encourage those of you interested
in questions of provenance and standards to
get involved in RDA or other groups like that.
There's national groups in addition to the
international.
Before we reinvent the wheel too many more
times because we've done a lot of reinvention
here.
One final thing in our last couple of minutes
here is maybe each of you could comment on
the role of data sharing,
of provenance, and the data science behind
it all in education and training at our universities
and schools of higher learning, and the role
that plays in training our next generation
of scientists.
I think it's kind of an auspicious question
because we are on the eve of some of the marches
for science which are going to be occurring
around the country.
And I think that's probably an important message
to convey and I was curious if either of you
had thoughts on that subject.
Yes.
So I'm currently helping Chris to teach this
class that she's been teaching for a long
time which is Data Management And Creation
And Policies For Research Data.
As a PhD student and future faculty in this
field, I really believe strongly in the role
of education and educating researchers in
understanding all the practices and the policies
around it to share and reuse, and how important
it is to make sure that their science that
they are conducting is open.
It's not just a matter of believing in open
science.
But you really have to know also how to do
it.
You really have to know how to curate the
data, what's submitted in the schema, what
are the requirements from the funders, and
so on.
So this is what Chris is teaching in her classes.
And I think the students here at the Information
Studies School, they're very interested in
this topic.
We often talk about how this should be a mandatory
class for all undergrad or graduate students
when they start approaching their research
context.
Yes and you are definitely trying to involve
more and more students from around the campus
and from different departments.
Yeah, Chris.
Perfect.
Just to wrap that up-- that was a real gift
of a question, Jack.
To wrap up on is I think it's a two-fold problem.
One is, as around it has very articulately
said, we need to embed notions of open science
and data practice in the graduate education
in pretty much every field.
It needs to be part of research methods from
the beginning.
But we also need to educate a generation of
data professionals.
And the information studies approach is to
think about this entire life cycle of data,
from the origins all the way through the long
term stewardship.
Whereas most of the data science programs
are much more about computation and analysis
and findings.
So I would like to see us produce a whole
generation that can be part of the research
teams, part of the university libraries and
archives, and part of the laboratory facilities,
to really think big picture and help build
that infrastructure.
And we're in early days, so I think we're
laying a good foundation.
Well with that, I want to thank Christine
Borgman and Irene Pasquetto for an absolutely
delightful presentation on data sharing, reuse,
and why it's hard to do.
And with some potential solutions in there
too.
Thank you so much.
That was just outstanding.
Really excited to have had you guys visit
with us today.
Thank you everyone.
And we'll see you next week at our next Big
Data [? 2 ?] Knowledge: Guide To The
Fundamentals Of Science.
Thank you again everyone.
Have a great weekend.
Thank you.